they live in a country of 100 million
people and there's a presidential
election coming up and in that
presidential election there are two
candidates there's candidate a there is
candidate a and candidate B and there's
some reality let's say I live in a very
decisive country and everyone is going
to vote for either and everyone
participates in election and everyone is
going to vote for either candidate a or
candidate B and so there's some
percentage there's some reality there
that P let me write it over here maybe 1
minus P percent let me do the P first
there's some reality that maybe P
percent will vote for B and I can switch
them around if I wanted so P percent are
going to vote for B and the rest of the
people are going to vote for a so maybe
one minus P percent are going to vote
for a one minus P and you might already
recognize that this is a Bernoulli
distribution there's one of there's one
of two values for a sample I can get and
right here the values I said your user
voting for candidate a or voting for
candidate B it's very hard to deal with
those values you can't calculate a mean
between a and B and all of that those
are letters they're not numbers so to
make us to make it manipulatable
mathematically we're going to say
sampling someone who's going to vote for
a is equivalent to sampling a zero and
sampling someone who's going to vote for
B is equivalent to sampling a one and if
you do that with a Bernoulli
distribution we learned in the video on
Bernoulli distributions that the mean
the mean of this distribution right here
the mean of this distribution right here
is going to be equal to P and it's a
pretty straightforward proof for how we
got that so the mean of this
distribution will which will actually be
not a value that this distribution can
take on is going to be someplace over
here and it is going to be equal to P
now my country has 100 million people it
is practically or it is definitely
impossible for me to be able to go and
ask all hundred million people who are
they going to vote for so I won't be
able to exactly figure out what these
parameters are going to be what my mean
is what P is going to be but instead of
doing that what I'm going to do is
do a random survey I'm going to sample
this population then get look at that
data and then get an estimate of what P
really is because this is what I really
care about I really care about P so I'm
going to try to estimate P with a sample
and then we're also going to think about
how good of an estimate that is so let's
say so I am going to randomly survey
randomly survey or sample randomly
survey one hundred one hundred people
and let's say I got the following
results let's say that 50 57 people say
that they were going to vote for person
a let me write it this way so 57 people
57 people say they're going to vote for
a or that's equivalent to getting 57
samples of zero and then the rest of the
people once again very decisive
population no one is undecided the rest
of the people so 43 people 43 people say
they're going to vote for B or that's
the equivalent of sampling 43 43 ones
now given this sample here what are my
what is my sample mean and my sample
variance my sample mean my sample mean
right here well that's just going to be
the average of these zeros and one so I
got 57 zeroes so it's going to be 57
times zero plus my forty three ones so
the sum of all of my samples
so it's 43 ones plus 43 times one over
the total number of samples I took over
100 so what does this what does this get
me so 57 so 57 times zero is zero 43
times one divided by 100 is zero point
four three that is my sample mean the
mean of just 100 data points that I
actually got now what is my sample
variance what is my sample variance
sample variance is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to the sum of my
squared distances to the mean divided by
my samples - one remember this is my
this is a sample variance and we want to
get the best estimator of the real
variance of the real variance of this
distribution and to do that you don't
divide by 100 you're going to divide by
100 - 1 we learned that many many videos
ago so what is what is my so I have 57
so I had 57 samples of 0 so I have 57 we
do it in that same yellow color 57
samples of 0 and so each of those
samples are 0 minus 0.4 3 away from the
mean right each of those samples are 0
you subtract 0.43 this is the difference
between 0 and point 4 3 and if I want
the squared distance I square it that's
how we calculate variance there's 57 of
those and then there's 43 times that I
sampled a 1 in my sample population 43
times I sample to 1 and the 1 is 1 minus
0.4 3 away from the mean because that is
the mean and I want to square that
distance and then I don't want to just
divide it by n I don't want to just
divide it by a hundred remember I'm
trying to estimate the true population
mean in order for this to be the best
estimator of that and I give you an
intuition of why many many videos ago we
divided by 100 minus 1 we divided by 100
minus 1 or 99 let's get the calculator
out to actually figure out our sample
variance let me get the calculator out
to get the calculator out and we have so
I'll do the numerator first I have 57 57
times 0 minus 0.4 3.43
squared + 43 + 43 times 1 minus 0.4 3
squared squared and then all of that all
of that divided by 100 - 1 or 99 divided
by 99 is equal to 0.2 4 7 5 so this is
equal to so my variance my
sample variance is equal to zero point
two four seven five and if I want to
figure out my sample standard deviation
I just take the square root of that my
sample standard deviation is just going
to be the square root of my sample
variance so I take the square root of
that value that I just had which is 0.49
seven so actually let me just round
let me just round that up as 0.50 so my
sample standard deviation is 0.5 oh now
if you just look at this you say okay
well your best estimate of the
percentage of people voting for a or B
is really what you just saw here your
best estimate or your best estimate of
the mean is that 43 percent of people
are going to vote for B and everyone
else is going to vote for a but an
interesting question is is how good of a
sample is that and it looks let's let's
take to the next level let's try to
think of an interval around 43 percent
that for which we are 95% we were
reasonably confident almost or roughly
95 percent sure that the real mean is in
that interval and let me make it very
clear
let me draw so this when we when we get
our sample mean we are sampling from the
sampling distribution of the sampling
mean and so let me draw that the
sampling distribution of the sample mean
so since we're since we're sampling from
a discrete distribution it's actually
going to be it's actually going to be a
discrete distribution but I'm going to
but it's going to have 100 possible
values right this can take on 100
different values here really anything
between 0 & 1 but I'll draw it kind of
continuous because it would be hard for
me to draw 100 different bars if I did
it would have a bar there you'd have a
bar there you know the the odds that
your sample mean would be one would be
it would be very low probability and
then you would have one more bar bar
like that a bar like that but that takes
forever to draw so I'm just going to
approximate it with this normal curve
right over there and so the sampling
distribution of the sample mean let me
write it over here so this is the
sampling distribution
sampling distribution of the sample mean
of the sample mean it has some mean here
it has some mean it has a mean and I can
denote it with the MU sub x-bar this
tells us this is the mean of the
sampling of the sample distribution but
we know from many many videos that this
is going to be the same thing as the
mean of the the population mean that we
are sampling from that each sample comes
from each of these hundred samples come
from so this is going to be equal to MU
which is going to be equal to P so this
is going to be equal to MU which is
equal to P now this variance over here
the variance of this distribution the
variance of this distribution let me
draw it like this right even better
let's say the standard deviation of this
distribution the standard deviation of
this distribution that distance right
over here the standard deviation the
standard deviation of the sampling
distribution of the sample mean we've
seen it multiple times already it's
going to be this standard deviation it's
going to be the standard deviation of
our population distribution so you know
that standard deviation is going to be
that distance over there so there's some
standard deviation associated with this
distribution it's going to be that
standard deviation divided by the square
root of our sample size and we saw many
videos ago why that at least
experimentally makes sense or why it
intuitively makes sense so it's going to
be the square root of 100 means square
root of 100 so it's going to be this guy
it's going to be that guy divided by 10
now we do not know what this guy is the
only way to figure out what that guy is
is to actually survey a hundred million
people which would have been impossible
so to estimate to estimate the standard
deviation of this we will use our
sampling standard deviation we will use
our sampling standard deviation as our
best estimate for the population
standard deviation so we can say
remember this is an estimate we cannot
come up the exact number for this just
from a SAN
but we can estimate it because this is
our best estimator for this standard
deviation and if we divide it by ten we
will have our best estimator for the
standard deviation of the sampling
distribution of the sampling mean so
remember this is just an estimate it is
just an estimate so you kind of have to
take everything after this point with a
little bit of a grain of salt so it's
going to be roughly equal to it's going
to be roughly equal to our an estimate
of it is going to be 0.5 it's going to
be 0.5 0.5 and remember every time we do
it take a different sample from here
this number is going to change so this
isn't like something in stone this is
dependent on our sample so it's going to
wiggle around a little bit depending on
what numbers we actually get in our
sample but it's going to be 0.5 oh this
is the S right here this is the S right
over here this point 5o divided by 10
which is equal to point zero five so our
best estimate of this standard deviation
is point zero five or you could even
view it as 5% now what I want to do is
come up with an interval around the
sample mean an interval around the
sample mean where I'm reasonably
confident using all of my estimates and
all of that where I'm reasonably
confident that there's a that or maybe
we say that I'm really confident that
there's a 95% chance there's a 95%
chance that the true mean that the true
mean is is within two standard
deviations or let me put it this way
there's a 95% chance that the true mean
is in that interval so let me write this
down I want to find an interval I want
to find an interval fine and interval
such that such that I am such that I am
reasonably confident reasonably
confident and I'm putting this kind of
touchy-feely language over here because
it's all around the fact that I don't
know for a fact that the standard
deviation is point zero five I'm just
estimating but I'm really easily
confident that the true that reason that
there is a 95% chance that the
there is a 95% chance that the true mean
of the population which is the same
thing as the proportion of the
population who are going to say we're
going to vote for person B or the
proportion of the population that are
going to be a1 so this is this is so
this is also you know we just have to
remember that mu that mu is equal to P
that the true P is in there's a 95%
chance that the true P is in that
interval and actually since I've already
gone 14 minutes into this video I'm
going to pause this video I'm going to
stop this video here and maybe I'll even
let you think about it just based on
what everything we've done so far we
figured out the sample mean I'm sorry we
figured out the sample mean right over
here we've figured out an estimate an
estimate for the I remember this is just
a sampling mean we don't know the true
this is the mean of our sample we don't
know the true Sam the true mean of the
sampling distribution and we also don't
know the true standard deviation of the
sampling distribution but we were able
to estimate it with the sample with the
sample standard deviation now everything
that we have so far and based on what
we've seen before on confidence
intervals and all that how can we find
an interval such that roughly and I'm
saying roughly because we had to
estimate the standard deviation that
there's a 95% chance that the true the
true mean of our population or that P
the proportion of the population saying
one is in that interval and we're going
to do that in the next video